ghazi muhammad's family is in mourning
the 24 year old from mad medini in
sudan's al jazeera state was killed
during an anti-military protest a week
ago
i was in khartoum someone called me and
said your brother was hit by a tear gas
canister
i called those who are with him and they
told me he had had a small injury when
in reality he was hit by a bullet to the
head
then i got a call from someone who gave
me his condolences
that's when i knew my brother had died
gassing was the one who supported this
family he dropped out of school to drive
an auto rickshaw whenever i called him
he was either at a funeral or at
weddings helping people
al-jazeera state has witnessed large
protests since the military took over
power in october dissolving a two-year
transitional government which was meant
to lead sudan to democracy security
forces have repeatedly used tear gas and
live ammunition against demonstrators
at least 78 protesters have been killed
and more than two and a half thousand
injured
with medany may not be the only city
besides the capital khartoum where
thousands have taken to the streets to
protest against military rule but its
location in central sudan is significant
it shows that the demand for civilian
rule and democracy transcends the social
and ethnic barriers that used to
dominate sudan's political landscape
for decades sudan's central region was
more stable than other areas which
suffered from civil wars but since
december 2018 when sudan's revolution
began many more people in cities closer
to the capital joined the
anti-government movement that movement
was reignited when the military took
control
the protest movement in wad madani is
not less than what is happening in
khartoum when two protesters from here
were killed including gasim people came
from all over the state and from
neighboring states we want to see the
future of those protesters who died
envisioned we want a democratic united
sudan
ghaziam's family say it may be painful
but they take comfort knowing he died
demanding change and to see a better
country hiba morgan al-jazeera with
madani sudan